Мене звати Майя і в мене дві мами
Люди часто дивуються, як так вийшло
але це не дивина
Вони люблять одна одну і мене
Саме через ці кілька речень у новій дитячій книжці Лариси Денисенко
ультраправі почали цькування письменниці
Чому – авторка не може збагнути
От скажіть ви мені чому – ви тільки що їх почули
дякую
Книга "Майя та її мами" – це історії сімнадцяти родин
діти з яких ходять до одного класу
Майя - це лише одна з героїнь
У кожного з її однокласників своя історія
і своя модель сім'ї
У когось лише одна мама
хтось живе із відчимом
хтось у родині ромів
А сама Майя – у родині ЛГБТ
Книга вчить дітей толерантності та прийняття різних сімей
Утім, реакція на книгу виявилася далеко не толерантною
особливо серед ультраправих
На їхню думку, "книга є прямим посяганням на
прищеплення школярам деструктивних принципів
що суперечать цінностям і традиціям
які споконвіку формувались в українських родинах"
Про це йдеться у листі-погрозі
адресованому організаторам форуму видавців у Львові
Саме в рамках форуму
дітям мали представити цю книгу
однак з міркувань безпеки презентацію скасували
бо ультраправі погрожували зірвати презентацію книги
Люди, які в насильницький спосіб намагаються
протидіяти абсолютно легітимним правам людини
котрі зазначені в Конституції, в конвенції
в законі проти дискриімнації
виглядають трохи варварськи
Це одна з перших книг
можлива, перша
де з дітьми намагаються говорити дорослою мовою
на дорослі теми і теми складні
Співфінансував видання книги німецький фонд імені Генріха Белля
Тут очікували, що частина українського суспільства
може виявитися неготовою до порушення такої теми
Проте не очікували, що реакція буде настільки радикальною
У фонді розчаровані, що презентацію книги скасували
Кожнен скасований захід виглядає так,
ніби ці погрози спрацьовують
Мені б не хотілося жити у суспільстві
де питання  вирішуються фізичними погрозами
Ми живемо у 21 столітті
Якщо ми досі будемо продовжувати вирішувати
питання фізичною силою
Тоді в Європу нам точно не порібно.
і дітям треба показувати і пояснювати
чому реальність така
Ми не можемо заплющвати очі
Дитина все одно про це дізнається
Майя не вигаданий персонаж
Така дівчинка справді живе в Україні з двома мамами
І таких родин в Україні немало
Однак більшість з них бояться відкрито заявляти про себе
Саме тому письменниця Лариса Денисенко
таки їде до Львова, щоб на інших
ще не скасованих заходах форуму видавців
розповісти про важливість толерантного ставлення до різних сімей
І змінити  думку людей щодо цього